so it has to be said john bolton is a
traitor to the interests of the United
States I believe John Bolton's
absolutely stunning claims in his book
about Donald Trump I believe John Bolton
is telling the truth as he sees it and
that the stories he tells in the book
are mostly accurate
I believe Trump okayed Weger
concentration camps in China I believe
Trump said invading Venezuela is cool I
believed from past China for help
getting reelected I believe Trump said
reporters should be imprisoned or
executed I believe Trump didn't know
that the UK had nuclear weapons why do I
believe it because it passes the sniff
test and it correlates it seems to be
corroborated by three and a half years
of similar claims about Donald Trump by
people who have been around him but John
Bolton is a traitor
why is John Bolton a traitor because he
waited seven months to make these claims
in public now you're going to see
criticisms of Bolton and of people on
the Left who essentially believe Bolton
is you know in broad strokes telling the
truth here you're starting to see some
people on the Left say you idiot
leftists you fell for the fake Russia
story
you fake fell for the fake Ukraine story
you fell for impeachment which was which
was never going to remove Donald Trump
which we said by the way and now you're
falling for the same type of nonsense
from a horrible guy who is a terrible
neocon and led us into war with Iraq and
blah blah blah blah blah no no no no no
that's not the case john bolton does not
get a pass here but just because
someone's a terrible person doesn't mean
everything they're saying is untrue
these allegations that john bolton is
making are so serious that it is an
inexcusable miscarriage of morality for
him to have waited seven months before
going public now I get it
Bolton has a book to sell you monetize
what you know and it made sense
financially for him to wait
number two the book was being vetted so
conceivably if Bolton just goes public
with all of this stuff in December
when the manuscript was turned over to
the National Security Council and it
hasn't yet been vetted
maybe there's a legal issue or whatever
the case may be but john bolton wants us
to believe that he's doing this because
it's for the good of the country to know
what Donald Trump has been up to behind
the scenes well I agree but if his
concerns are the good of the country we
should have known about it seven months
ago or eight or nine months ago or you
know a lot of this stuff happened even
earlier and and john bolton could have
talked about it at the time I cannot
forgive john bolton for that if 5% of
what bolton claims in the book is true
there would have been multiple cases for
impeaching donald trump now with the
republican-controlled senate trump still
wouldn't have been convicted and removed
on impeachment but john bolton has
criticized democrats for not going after
Trump more strongly on more issues on
impeachment well he could have told us
what some of those issues were he
refused to testify before the House
impeachment committee unless he was
subpoenaed which is not uncommon but
again if bolton is the patriot who's
telling us this because the country
deserves to know he could have figured
out a way to tell us the seven eight
nine months ago
aside from testifying at any point in
time john bolton could have said you
know what this is so serious this is so
important that i am going to take a
personal legal risk and i'm gonna do
interviews and i'm gonna talk about what
i saw he still could have written a book
people still would have bought the book
seven months later but he could have
given us seven months of a headstart and
many things could have gone differently
in the last seven months bolton writes
in his book that when he saw Trump asked
China for help getting reelected he
believed it was a threat to American
interests and he said nothing he was
national security adviser his concern is
national security and he said nothing
about something that he believed to be a
threat to US interests Bolton the
patriot sees a threat is in charge of
national security and waits to publish a
book in order to go public that is not
patriotic
that is not patriotic so
Colten going public on all this stuff as
eli Hoenig wrote in an op-ed for CNN
bolton could have changed the course of
history
had he gone public 7 months ago with
this stuff so do I believe Bolton is
making this stuff up I don't I believe
Bolton is telling the truth as he sees
it and that the book is mostly accurate
maybe there are some details that are
not because all of the claims line up
with what we've known about Donald Trump
for three and a half years none of these
claims seem outlandish in the context of
what we know about Donald Trump but in
the same way that Donna John Bolton
betrayed the country in 2003 by pushing
the Iraq war Bolton betrayed the United
States by waiting 7 months to make these
claims public these are things that he
knew would have been worthy of
impeachment and he waited for the
opportunity to make money by selling
books now let's get back to what I know
many of you are going to say why does it
matter about impeachment impeachable
claims if a Republican Senate would not
have removed Trump either way that is
true but it would have been much worse
for the Senate to acquit Trump in light
of five impeachable offenses most of
them even crazier than the Ukraine story
then to impeach it into acquit Trump
only on the Ukraine story Trump directly
asked China for support getting
reelected he told China concentration
camps are the right thing to do Trump
obstructed investigations into Turkish
individuals and businesses as a favor to
our toe on seeing Republicans acquit
Trump in light of five solid impeachment
cases might have been a difference maker
in some of the upcoming reelection
campaigns of senators in November that's
one example that what would be a
material difference there is no way that
Boulton going public earlier helps Trump
and it might have hurt Trump and it
might have hurt Republicans hugely so
Bolton was and still is an outrageous
war Hawk who wants to see American
military personnel in more places around
the world for corporate profits or
neoconservative political goals john
bolton probably is at least partially
motivated
by a bruised ego related to how
everything went down with donald trump
but john bolton is not going to just
make up everything that he said in the
book and yet he is still a traitor the
right thing to do if it's out of love of
country would have been for him to make
these claims publicly seven months ago
he cannot be forgiven for that but that
doesn't mean what he's saying in the
book is untrue and a lot of these lame
just lame lame lame hot takes from some
supposedly lists completely ignore that
bolton can be a bad guy and the claims
can still be true trump can have done
the things bolton alleges and yet it
could still have been wrong for bolton
to make the case to go into iraq which
it was wrong and i hope that we don't
see much of the left go down that this
very very wrong headed rabbit hole let's
take a quick break we will talk about
the economy coming up we will talk about
coronavirus a lot more news in the last
24 hours
than merely john bolton if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinka stinka slits
you consume an entire book on your way
home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just fifteen minutes and you get all
of the important core ideas and
information from that book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do or if you
just want to sample a book before you
buy the entire thing i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash pack
I've put the link right underneath this
video